hi I'm sorry come come I'm Michael and
I'm gay
it's awesome thank you so we have a
podcast coming out about being gay and
what that means or no we have a podcast
about sexuality oh how about this I'll
ask you what is the podcast about it's
about sexuality hmm it's out now so goes
into it oh god my hands Robert Angier
when did everybody know that they were
gay literally my birth literally I had a
boyfriend in like kindergarten I promise
[Music]
we brought together seven gay men I'm
gay I'm gay I'm gay I'm gay I'm gay I'm
gay
I am gay one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives he or she wins the
entire prize
[Music]
when did everybody come out I came out
what house 1817 my mom actually asked me
what I tried to tell her she basically
took the reins and she's like I okay
oh wait I was a little bit later so I
kind of hid it for a long time I was
like 23 it was like an anxiety around
cuz it's so short you can't really say
anything so I was like let me say
something so then I'm not the one that
doesn't say anything before the round is
over I came out to my sisters when I was
17 and then I came out to my when I was
21 cuz she found a [ __ ] running in my
room like what is this and I was like I
guess I just based it off of appearances
he maybe doesn't fit the gay stereotype
I just voted cuz I was like let me just
get someone out long as it's not me you
[ __ ] it's not me sometimes people
tell me I'm not I don't like necessarily
look gay or quote/unquote what people
might assume looks gay just take them
long hair and maybe the clothes just
take very I wanna say bland
no judgment we were all on a baseball
team would you consider yourself a
pitcher or a catcher I'm a catcher
pitcher okay I put in codes okay yeah
pick ten cats I want to say yeah more we
catch her okay I even feel like the most
obvious question it's like when that
everybody know that they were gay
at what age the birth literally my birth
literally I had a boyfriend in like
kindergarten I promise literally his
name is Christopher and we kissed on the
slide in like kindergarten and I was
like I'm gay mine was really suppressed
during high school if no one knows I'm
trans so I have two coming-out stories
so that's very difficult to come out to
your parents multiple times well yeah
technically I had to come out three
times one I thought I was a lesbian
because I was born a woman so I thought
okay that's a thing and then after that
I was
no I'm trans so I had to come out again
after that and then I was like yeah I'm
gay too many times I mean he had three
times where you came out which I get you
can come in you can go out you can come
and go out but I'm just like I don't
know that's way too many times
for me it was just so repressed because
my dad I'm super homophobic and you know
which happens a lot in the black
community so yes super heavily protected
and guarded and then it just kind of
came to a point in my life where like I
realized like this is my life I need to
you know do something for myself and not
living that fear so of course I ran away
to San Francisco and and that kind of
helped me like accept it more so it's
really nice thank you for sharing that I
was just gonna ask who here was bullied
in high school for being gay well I
suppress mine so yeah I was getting
bullied since middle school I mean I
wasn't saying like I was gay but they're
like you sound like a girl you're gay
and I would be like like rumors go
around about me when I was like denying
it so I was like super pissed and I like
I don't care has anyone had sex with a
girl you have I was very drunk pulled
out after 15 seconds to her face I think
this is actually disgusting we're back
in the house he felt a little quiet and
reserved can I just didn't pick up on a
lot of gayness from Rico wasn't
mentioning a lot like he would put in
his two cents but wouldn't I feel like
it was surface level
I saw the on the run tour jacket that he
was wearing and I thought maybe he was
kind of using that to kind of like trick
us all into thinking he was like a
Beyonce fan so I was just like let me
get him out
good luck guys
okay so what's everybody's favorite part
about our community very they're more
accepting yeah yeah and super open it's
nice to have a community of people that
are they've been do the same thing
you've been through so they get it
exactly I love how we're like basically
just one but like we have the same story
but it's like different you know fashion
sense let's talk about relationships
right who is in a relationship not I I
don't know what that is so X is when was
when was your last ex
mine was about two or three years ago
and I broke up with him because he was
still in the closet and I'm like just
out there I don't have time for that my
hummock go to a public I wanna hold your
hand and um the good thing about it
though is like I helped him come out so
like when he told me about that I
started to cry I was in my car was like
[ __ ] I don't have don't have an ex never
a minute situation like I didn't like
talking to people but it was in high
school and I was like straight okay
I was just really suspicious because
every time people started mentioning
like just relationships or just
interacting with other men he really
couldn't go that much in death who did
everybody listen to I'm sorry guys I
think we're not as poppy Megan the
stallion you were right here right here
I think she had that one album that was
there I feel like is Nikki know
[Music]
he wasn't giving me enough a part of me
was thinking what he might just be just
a well-dressed person was bella thorne
one side TTYLXOX and then there before
ya around I see a tattoo of a lady on
your honor
yes what inspired her I've dealt with
depression and self-harm and stuff like
that
so when I'm dealing with that stuff this
is how I feel I feel like I just have
myself so that's why she's like hugging
gotchas yeah why not get a man yeah I
feel like you like women if you have a
tattoo of a woman what did y'all do
throughout high school Oh like sports I
did performing arts people didn't know
right because I did musical theater I
did choir dance I did a little bit of
football like a little bit I know always
attempted every year to like play
football then it always stopped when it
came time to actually play football so I
kind of still don't even really know how
to play football I train with them
what's your guys is like tight like when
it comes like a guy similar-looking
build an appearance but personality-wise
I really prefer like more feminine
personality okay families have to be
confident so I do kind of like on the
taller side of things I've been
surprised though I don't have a type you
guys I really don't know I'm just like
if you can vibe with me if you think
wasn't the same music I listen to we can
like do some activities go hiking go
you know it's all good no matter what
you look like no matter who you are come
to me I really didn't want to have that
last round I kind of figured we were all
gay but being selfish I just wanted it
to be two of us let's go back to that
guy that you dated who was in the closet
so where is he now did you guys get back
together after he came out no because
when I I also fell out of love with him
so I was like I can't I can't I tried to
get back with him and I was with him for
a while and I was like why the [ __ ] am i
doing this like I'm sorry I don't like
you anymore
okay okay once we started that round and
I think I went and gave him a question
like right away and he answered it and I
didn't feel he was lying so I was like
oh crap
that's the only question I had for him I
[Laughter]
knew they were gonna say that
okay I'm gay as [ __ ] I've been sucking
dick can a straight person do this Oh
tens across the board no okay
I'm gay cuz I mean it took a while to
come to grips with it but you know after
coming to grips to it just kind of
seeing and kind of showing it become a
different colors and different styles
and different you know everything so
there's no one right way to be gay just
like there's no right way to be straight
you know especially we're in such a time
where you know it's good to have
representation of just the whole
spectrum of everyone to the show we're
all connected we're all together you
know there's someone watching who you
know is in the same situation I was in
it's nice to be able to see that and be
able to be like okay so there's a way
you can still be yourself and still not
feel secluded I am gay literally and
what straight man - you know could be
his face like this literally I'm saying
get into it this off glam I'm just
saying like I'm 100% me I'm authentic
like I'm gay I love men I've always
loved man I don't know what else y'all
want from me at this point
what I'm sorry you did me wrong by for
sure didn't do you wrong
so it's 125 each I'm good confident yeah
I'll see him out too many times I was
like one of those times as you went back
in there I don't - well it was risky
coming out to the group here as
transgender cuz a lot of people
invalidate just trans people in general
in the first place a lot of people still
classify me as a lesbian and often times
I do get it within the gay community I
actually had a very strong feeling about
Marcos home that get-go I believed like
100% my gaydar and straight are very
poor they're horrible I think it was
important to do this to kind of show
people that there's you know spectrum of
human beings and even if you identify
with one group that's not all who you
are
it's a done deal we did it me and Martel
now we have to clean it all up right
[ __ ] thank you for watching